へへっ
チャンネル登録者400万人突破しましたあああ！！！！！
イエエエエエエエエエイ！！！！
一人だった。。。
ひとまず乾杯！
お疲れ様でーーす
うわぁ
俺もおっさんになったな
はい、というわけでですね
改めまして、チャンネル登録者数が400万人いきました
ここまで見てくださった皆様
チャンネル登録してくださってる皆様
いつもコメントしてくださる皆様
評価押してくださる皆様
本当にありがとうございます
今日は語るぞ
今の心境を皆様にお伝えしようかなと思いまして
400万人は多分、日本初だと思います
400万人ってもう分かんなすぎる
ああそうだ、日本初ですな
日本初でございます
400万人ってどういう数字なんだろうねぇ
400万人ってどれくらいなんだろう
もうね、分かんない
想像がつかないんですけど
分かりやすい例えで言うと2009年のyahoo知恵袋の登録者数が大体400万人くらいだったらしいです
いまいち分からんな
いまいち分からないんですけども
もう本当にね、多分僕の想像している以上に大勢の方が見ており
まあ、その分色んな人の目に留まると
まあ全員がね、これは面白いっていうわけはなく
面白くないっていう意見も増えたし
面白いって言ってくださる方も増えたし
本当にね、様々な意見がすごい見れるようになりました
うん、本当そうだと思います
本当に応援してくださる方に「ホントありがとう」って思うんですけど
やっぱその分ね、批判とかも増えて
そこは、なんとか本当に応援してくださる皆様がいたからね
気にせず、ここまでね乗り切れたのかなと思っております
美味っ
なんなんだろうね
ひとまず、おでん食べるお
まあ、なんかこう、毎回言うんですけど
僕の動画は
面白くありません
面白くないけど
ひょっとしたら面白いやつもあるかも知れないんですけど
基本的につまんない動画もあります
つまんない動画もあるし、面白い動画もあるし、意味が分からない動画もあると思う
それも含めて、俺のやりたい動画なので
面白くないって言われても、それはそれでそういう意見なんだなって、最近思っていいんですけど
色んなyoutuberさんのお話を聞くと、批判が最近酷い人も多くて
そういう人を見てるとね、心無いコメントはよろしくないなと思います
コメント欄、好きなこと書いていいって言うけどさ
人としてのマナーとか、ネチケットっていうんですけど、ネットのエチケットとかあるんですけど
本当に面白くなかったり、嫌いだったら動画見ないと思うので
他のyoutuberさん、批判などは気にせず一緒に頑張りましょう
400万人ねぇ
今後なんですけども、どうしようかな
俺自体は、何したいか分かんなくなってきちゃって
ひとまず、有名になりたいって言ってyoutube始めて
一応、日本一の登録者数まできて、正直
何処を目指せばいいのか分かんなくなってきております、今
自分のやりたいことは、本当に自分のやりたい動画を撮ってるだけなんで
現状に満足しちゃってて
この上がないんですよね
美味ぇな
パッケージ可愛いよね
何を目指していいか分かんなくなっちゃって
そうも言ってられないし、もう僕自体、大学卒業して
youtubeを仕事にしてるんで
どんどん次のステップに行こうと思っておりまして
今ですね、まだ具体的に言えないんですけど
ちょっと今、普通に意味不明なくだらない動画投稿を毎日してるんですけど
それの上のステップに行くために、ちょっと今色々と動いておりまして
youtubeで毎日動画出してて、楽しい日常もいいんですけど
もっと上のステップにいってなんかもっと凄いこと出来ればいいなと思ってて
なんやかんや動いております
それでバタバタしてることも、たまにあるんですけども
いつか皆さんにきっとお知らせ出来るので、少々お待ちくださいませ
次、でも楽しそうだよ。今やってることは
美味ぇ
最高に美味ぇな
とりあえずですね、youtubeは今すごい楽しくやらせて頂いてますが
もっと他になにか出来ないかなと思っていて、色々挑戦しております
まずは、それをちょっと皆さんにお伝えしておきたかったです
僕が今どこにいて、どこに向かっているのか
そして、この先何をしたいのか
ん？
何が言いたいのか分かんなくなっちゃった
あ゛あ゛
400万人だよ！
一、十、百、千、万、十万、百万、四百、四百
うるりぅれりゅ
お、俺ちょっと酔ってんのかなw
あー、分かんないや
本当もう感謝でいっぱいです、皆さんには
おでんはね
あ、汚っ
味噌をかけると見た目がよろしくないな
本当に皆さんありがとうございます、いつも
僕の今後のスタンスのお話なんですけども
まあ、youtubeに今までいつも通りあげてるんだけども
やっぱり、日本一になってからね
はっはっはっはは！！
ははっはっははあ！！！
俺がナンバーワンyoutuberだ！！
俺より、面白いyoutuberなどこの世にいない！！
はっはっは！
これからも最高に面白い動画を出していくぜ！！
ふええあああああ！！
みたいな感じではないですね
そういう感覚ではないんだな
まあ、こうプレッシャーもありますよ
てか、プレッシャーがすごい、最近
プレッシャーがすごいんですよ！
あんまり、こんなこと動画で言わないな
いや、あの、僕あんまり仮面とか被れないタイプなんです
実はすごい不安なのに、「僕はがんばります」みたいな
そういう思ってもないこと、あまり言えないので
正直に僕の今の心境を話しますね
そうなんですよ、、
プレッシャーが凄いんですよ
なんやかんや、やってる事はつまんないんですけど
日本一のチャンネルなので
やはり、皆様のハードルも上がってきてるんではないでしょうか
結構、派手なこともしますしね、たまに
たまに派手なこともするんですけど
それを毎日やるっていうのは、僕のしたいことではないので
たまにそういう派手なことが出来れば、僕も楽しいなっていう感じで
すごいハードルが上がって、面白い動画を出さなきゃって思っちゃうんですけど
出来ればそうは思いたくないかな
常に初心ではいたいですけど、やっぱプレッシャーはついてまわるんですよ、、
でもやっぱり初心でいたいので、僕は面白い動画を出すんじゃなくて
今まで通りのスタンスで
あ、食べながらごめんね
今まで通りのスタンスで、昔から言ってるように見てる皆さんを楽しませる動画を作りたわけじゃなくて
自分が作ってて楽しめる動画を作りたいと思っております
そこが僕のコンセプトなので
僕が楽しい動画を作ります
それで、皆さんも楽しめたら一番いいなという感じです
400万人となると影響力とか色々考えなきゃいけないこともあって
なかなか、したいことをバンバン出来ないというところもご理解していただければと思っております
非常に肩身が狭い、、
もうなんかしたらすぐ起きますからね！
僕が例えばなんだろう、家が爆発する実験をしたら
ひょっとしたら、かなり大勢の子供達がその実験の真似をするかもしれない
そうなると、ひょっとしたら日本中で爆発がおきるかもしれない
責任者は私です
出来ることが制約されてきておりますが、僕はその中でなるべくしたいことを出来ればいいなと思っております
こういうことは普段の動画で言わないんですけど
隠しててもしょうがないし、皆さんにも分かって欲しいなと思うので
まあ、なかなか大きな数字を持つと
それなりの責任とか、周りのことをどうしても気を使わなければならない場面が出てきます
まあ、でもなんかね、しょうもない動画が好きなので
ド派手な爆発とかはたまにいいと思っているので
まあ、これからも今自分が出来る範囲で頑張っていこうと思います
あーー
モジャイクだな、これは
伝わったかな～、俺の言いたいこと
上手く言えないんですけど、とりあえず僕は
もう、一位とかあんまり興味ないです
いや、ありますよ！
出来れば一位でいたいと思いますけど
そんなこと気にしてたら、面白い動画を出せないと思ってるんで
まあ、プレッシャーが非常に怖い
プレッシャーが非常に怖いが、逃げていても仕方がない
だから僕は！何も気にせず！いつも通り！
テキトーに動画出すという話でございます！
うん、それが一番大事だよ！
もう、色々あるじゃないですか！
千円ガチャすれば再生されるとかさ
ふんっ！俺やってて本当に面白いのかって、僕は思いますよ
面白いなら良いんですけど
俺も今度やろ
僕はもう、次のステップに進んでると思いたいので
youtubeに動画を出すのは非常に楽しいんですけど
他の人を気にせず、自分のやりたいように適当にやらせていただきます！
ていう話を皆様にしたかった
俺がダイナマイトを使ってトミックさんにドッキリを仕掛けるのはいつになるんだろう
ていうお話です
伝わったかなあ～！
多分、全然伝わってないと思う！ごめん！
俺も何言いたいかよく分かんなくなってきちゃった
ひとまずね、ひとまず！
本当にここまでついてきてくださった皆様ありがとうございます
僕は
自分が楽しければいいなと思っております
それはもうずっと初期から言ってきたことなので、その軸だけはブレません！
なので本当にね
面白い動画、つまんない動画、色んな動画あると思いますが
これからもね！良かったら、暇だったらでいいので
苦笑いとかでもいいので
たまにでもいいので！
僕のチャンネルに遊びに来てくれたら嬉しいです
もうねぇ、本当にツイッターとか見てるとね、凄い沢山の方から応援されてるなっていうのが
ヒシヒシと伝わってきてね
僕はもう、、、
だめだ、ここで泣いたらダメだーーー！！！
ここで泣いたらダメだけど、本当に沢山の方におめでとうって言われて、僕はホントに幸せ者です
言いたいことは言えたかな
登録者数が少ないときは好き勝手出来たけど、そうもいかないけど
その中で僕は自由に楽しんでいきたいと思います
数字というものは怖いぞ
僕はここにきてそれを思い知りましたんで
ウインナー美味っ！
バナナとビール合わな！！
もう本当に皆さん、あんまり期待しないでくだいねw
あんまり期待しないでいいんですけど、まあ緩く暇だったら、また動画見に来てください
でも！ホントに凄い応援してくださる方もいるので
バナナ収納
凄い応援してくれてる皆、本当にいつもありがとうございます
これからもよろしくお願いします
本当に皆さんに支えられているので
というわけでこれからも！はじめしゃちょーの成長をぜひ！見守っていただけると有難いでございます！
進化し続けます！！！
しないこともあるかもしれません
数字は気にしたくないんですけども、切りのいい数字なので
言いたいこと言わせていただきました！
じゃあな！！
おやすみ～